I want you to for a moment think about
playing a game of Monopoly
except this games been rigged and you've
got the upper hand we brought in more
than a hundred pairs of strangers into
the lab and with the flip of a coin
randomly assigned one of the two to be a
rich player in a rigged game they got
two times as much money when they passed
go they collected twice the salary and
they got to roll both dice instead of
one so they got to move around the board
a lot more as the game unfolded we saw
dramatic differences begin to emerge
between the two players the rich player
started a move around the board louder
literally smacking the board with their
piece as he went around less and less
sensitive to the plight of those poor
poor players more likely to showcase how
well they're doing now this game of
Monopoly can be used as a metaphor for
understanding society where in some
people have a lot of wealth and a lot of
status and a lot of people don't what
we've been finding is that as a person's
levels of wealth increase their feelings
of compassion and empathy go down and
their feelings of entitlement of
deserving this increases wealthier
individuals are more likely to endorse
unethical behavior at work like stealing
cash from the cash register taking
bribes lying to customers the wealthier
you are the more likely you are to
pursue a vision of personal success to
the detriment of others around you but
we've been finding that small changes to
people's values can restore levels of
egalitarian ISM and empathy for instance
reminding people of the benefits of
cooperation or the advantages of
community cause wealthier individuals to
be just as egalitarian as poor people